i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle on a very busy friday night so
we're gonna dive right in
our vanishing president that's the focus
of tonight's angle
there might be and i emphasize
might be some good news regarding the
ukraine russia conflict tonight
turkey's leader ray yep erdogan said
russia and ukraine are nearing a peace
deal according to his account again we
take it with a grain of salt
a consensus regarding such issues as
nato disarmament collective security and
using russian as an official language in
the technical infrastructure works
during the ongoing process in belarus
now of course
if that's true there still remain deep
disagreements about the status of the
breakaway provinces in eastern ukraine
but russia did say last night that its
military operation if that's what you
want to call it uh in ukraine was mostly
complete and that going forward it would
focus primarily on the eastern part of
the nation
now this is actually if true a big shift
and may indicate that russia
after inflicting heinous pain and
suffering on the ukrainian people
has now limited its goals in ukraine
now if america actually had a strong
leader a real president
he'd find a way right now to capitalize
on these potential breakthroughs
and encourage everyone all parties to
hammer out a peace deal and do it as
soon as possible
now this would save countless lives and
prevent more suffering
but instead we have joe biden who comes
off as kind of a
a distant observer of all of this not
the leader of the free world there's
negotiations that are discussions i
should say that have taken place that i
have not been part of including
ukrainians
and it's uh it's it's their judgment to
make now first he had to disappear from
the campaign trail remember in 2020
because of covid
now he's vanishing from the world stage
taking a back seat to lesser powers in
nato
he's just waiting for his marching
orders at this point meanwhile he is
previewing the wonderful future all of
us americans are going to have to look
forward to under his watch we did we
talked about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
bread basket in the world
ukraine and russia but we the united
states are going to do our part because
we're the third largest producer of
wheat in the world
now an american president is supposed to
reassure us
biden just terrifies us he depresses us
but just in case you haven't heard
enough from him he will have more
tomorrow on the crisis of course the
same crisis that never would have
occurred under president trump
and you can bet that american taxpayers
will be forced to foot the bill once
again
he will give a major address tomorrow
that will speak to the stakes of this
moment
the urgency of the challenge that lies
ahead what the conflict in ukraine means
for the world
wait did he say means for the world
now mr i've met more foreign leaders
than anyone alive hasn't had one foreign
policy success under his belt
unless you call us afghanistan
withdrawal a win for america
but we do know one thing
under biden's watch china always ends up
with the longer end of the stick
the ccp is laughing learning and
plotting as biden flails and
flounders from one crisis to the next
now even when president biden tries to
be empathetic
with all of the tragedy unfolding for
the ukrainian people he somehow manages
to botch it
when you see
a
30 year old woman standing there in
front of a tank with a
with a rifle
i mean
talk about what happened in tiananmen
square
that's tiananmen square square
he actually say that's gentleman square
squared
how profound
now why hasn't biden released the
transcript of that big call he had a few
weeks ago with president xi by the way
shouldn't the american people know what
was said what was perhaps negotiated
away
we know china's state media and all
their outlets indicated that biden had
agreed to play nice on all the issues
important to the ccp but of course we
don't really know what the truth is
because biden's people refused to be
transparent about what if anything he
offered china in return for their help
with russia
now not only though is china acting as a
backstop for russia's war effort in
ukraine it's right now expanding its
influence and reach as american
officials are distracted in eastern
europe
a disturbing report today that president
xi is hashing out the final details of a
secret security agreement with the
solomon islands that tiny island nation
strategically situated
off northern australia not too far from
new zealand either
now tipping the balance of power toward
china in the indo-pacific well that move
represents a serious threat to our
allies and frankly to u.s interests
once again
american weakness has far-reaching
implications none of them good
there is no question that the balance of
security in the region would be affected
said peter jennings executive director
of the australian strategic policy
institute think tank
it would enormously complicate
australia's ability to move subs and
ships and aircraft along the australian
east coast they'll be watched from the
solomon islands
so once again
china has out-maneuvered a feeble-minded
u.s president
who seems more worried about getting
home to delaware for the weekend than
the geopolitical storm clouds ahead
and beyond the president himself china
knows it doesn't face any obstacles or
any real calls for accountability from
any members of biden's cabinet either
they don't need more lobbyists in dc and
china now they have biden's treasury
secretary janet yellen
would you consider sanctions on china as
an ally of russia at this point so i
don't think that that's necessary or
appropriate at this point we had senior
administration
officials are talking privately and
quietly with china to make sure that
they
understand our position
oh they understand it all right
secretary ellen
weakness
is very easy to spot and very easy to
understand
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else